an existing broadc crested Spillway has
a current design discharge of 2,000
cubic feet per second a Crest length of
50 ft and a design head of 7 ft due to
climate change considerations it is
planned to upgrade the spillway to
handle discharge rates of 2700 cubic
feet per second if there is 10 ft of
length available to increase the crest
length of the spillway how much higher
will the head of the upgraded Spillway
be than it was originally in feet assume
that the velocity coefficient of
discharge does not
change so this problem is pretty
straightforward the first thing you have
to know is that a Spillway is a type of
Weir searching Weir in the reference
manual will take us to page
319 the problem notes that this is a
broad crusted Spillway so let's look for
the section on Broad crusted
Weirs on page 320 the horizontal broad
crusted Weir equation can be written as
followed Q equal 2 over 3 *
CV * l e * the square < TK of
2G time h e raised to 3/
2 in this equation Q is going to be
discharged in cubic feet per second CV
is the velocity coefficient of discharge
L is the effective Weir length and H E
is the energy head Upstream of the
Weir and G is 32.2 feet perss squared
AKA
gravity so if we write down our known in
this equation we can see that only one
term is missing and that's going to be
CV so let's first solve for CV using the
initial conditions of the spillway
so we
have
2,000 cubic feet per second equals 2
over 3 *
CV * L is going to be 50
ft time the sare < TK 2 *
32.2 feet per second squared and all of
that is square
rooted and then the design head is 7
ft raised to the 3/
2 so if we isolate CV right now what we
can do is multiply by three across the
equal sign then divide by all of the
other terms so 2 50 this
quantity and the value that comes out of
7 raised to the 3 over2 and that should
get you a CV of 0.
four so now that we have this CV and the
problem states that the coefficient of
discharge here isn't going to change
between designs what we can do is use
that value along with the changes for
the upgraded Spillway so changes to the
flow and length to solve for the new
head so the new discharge rate is
2700 cubic feet per second and that's
going to be equal to 2
over3 CV is now
0.4 the spillway isn't 50 ft anymore but
50 plus the 10
additional so we have 60 ft
here then times 2 *
32.2 feet per second squared squ square
rooted and now h e is our unknown
term that we're solving
for so same thing
here if we were to multiply by three
then divide by two for 60 and this
quantity we could get h e raised to the
3 over2 which is sometimes just where I
stop if I don't trust myself to get it
all in the calculator at
once equals about 2 1 ft and then
therefore the new head equals about
7.61
ft now the problem
asks how much higher will the head of
the spillway be when it's upgraded than
it was originally so really what we have
to do now is 7.61 minus 7 which is the
original and that'll get us
0.61 ft which 0.5 is our closest answer
over over
here so that's all it takes to solve
this problem um this is a basic Weir
problem that just requires you to
understand that you need the broad
crested Weir equation so when you think
Spillway think
Weir and the first thing we're going to
do is solve for one
unknown then we're going to plug that
unknown which is now a known back into
the problem again with new values added
to the other terms
and that's
it